foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
I got an apple
and a banana
8 30.
oh yeah that's when I had the stream set
to I changed the time like three four
times today
I was like am I ready am I not am I
gonna do this am I gonna do that
whatever
we're here now
uh we're gonna try and beat the main
game today
and then
[Music]
we'll do DLC
we'll see how far we get today I think
we can get pretty far
[Music]
we are pretty strong
well you get a different notification
every time I change the time
[Applause]
that's crazy
well good morning
but I'm eating my Apple
and put that there
I'm doing great zombie how are you all
doing today
where did we leave off
I didn't stream yesterday because I had
some [ __ ] going on
where do we leave off what do we do
foreign
I think
after trying to do
that's right we were trying to do
siegwards questline
and it ended up in him dying in about
five seconds against yorm and when he's
dead he stays dead
excellent
[Music]
excellent
we're looking good though
if we beat yorm
let me smack his head down here
[Music]
put him right here
[Music]
slint
we beat the abyss Watchers we can put
their head down as well
return them to their Thrones because
they're [ __ ]
we had to do it for him boom
look at that so now we gotta get
Aldrich which I believe is over there
and then we gotta get the twin princes
[Music]
all of which are a bunch of [ __ ]
[Music]
we gotta turn them back
that's how this works
so
we need to go to
stew
[Music]
pots of Sullivan and get through the
rest of the area
what any are you going for I just the
regular one
we'll see we'll see what we got toward
the end you know
I think we can do this first
and then we can fight the dancer
because what we once we beat Aldridge
it'll just send us straight to the
dancer
which I think is pretty cool
am I fat rolling why
why do I be fat rolling right now
ew
oh I think this is just straight up too
heavy
I want to wear the herald armor I like
the herald armor a lot let's go to that
I mean at least we should be able to
nope still fat rolling am I just weak
okay that's what I had
maybe the helmet's too much
we'll take it
are we human
or are we dancers
are you fat I don't think so not anymore
oh God here we go
we got a couple of weenies up here
also
fireball shot at you the entire time
yep these guys
I'm gonna bring him over here
what are weird answers
come up here
I don't want the fireballs
are they coming
one of them is
actually perfect
get that [ __ ] out of here bro
you're gonna poke me to death huh
I'm actually about to get poked to death
excellent
fine it's all part of the game
yeah I could kill you never mind keep
I don't like this
plunging attack
you're lucky your boy's here to save you
sir
freaking easy
when you're not double teaming me
like a bunch of [ __ ]
did all the abyss Watchers sit at one
throne
I mean you think about it now
damn
big ass Arrow just shot me in the foot
wouldn't it be like one or two are alive
at a time for the abyss Watchers
large titties we love that
just gonna stay in my foot huh I love it
I'm just gonna run
yep
almost took an arrow to the knee
I used to be an adventurer like you
then I took an air to the meeting
I think this is a secret right yep
what was this area again
isn't this where we fought gwyndolin
in Dark Souls 1.
leading to
I mean is this the bedroom
where we see big chests ahead
I feel like the layout's different
what up Garrett
yes Skyrim references reversal
ring males can perform female actions
and vice versa
interesting
this is where you get married
where do we get married
in Dark Souls 1
well this is a tomb
it's cute they put some flowers up there
this is where we get married to Anri oh
how do we do that I want to do that
Andre's still alive
pretty cool place
you won't get married because you killed
assassin oh
how does that affect that what
I feel like the quests are more
complicated in this game than they are
in Elven ring
Henry is the opposite sex of the gender
you choose no matter what hence the
reversal ring oh yeah I forgot about
that like if you started the game as a
girl then honor you would be a boy
yeah that's right
well we gotta do the the secret over
here too
talk to our girl
take a bite of my Apple
actually
marrying in this game involves her dying
that's where the Assassin comes in
how do I marry someone who's dead
you know what never mind Welcome To Dark
Souls
thank you dire Dyer I appreciate you
all right
if you don't know what this is you're
going to be really confused the apple is
really good
yep
yep
yep yep
there it doobie
hello name thyself stranger I'm Jake
I am yoshka
den of the Dark Moon Knights
what that can be to such a place I don't
know
should I do this
true true
yes okay
thanks too
very well
Captain to this nightless company I
remain
is this the melon a voice actor
thousand percent melano voice actor
thus journeyed far
hear my voice
if Thou shalt swear by the Covenant to
become a shadow of Father Gwynne and
sister Guinevere
a blade that shall hunt the foes of our
Lords
then I place thee unto the Aegis and the
power of the dark moon why is she just
chill in here
thank you Mommy
that now a blade of the Dark Moon augers
the only night of our company
swear this oath I'm the only one in the
night Duty
cool
he's a prisoner he doesn't look in
prison oh
good blade of the Dark Moon
welcome home I was like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here bro if I can provide
the sucker only tell me how
provide me sucker
did I give her this
I have Uno proof of a Concord kept
Hoggers my lady
okay
open at Legion steep
okay long ago our father Quinn
commenting the waning of the fire
became Cinder of his own will
now the fire is linked by the Champions
who have come in his Stead
like me such as the will of father and
the Gods
and so the Dark Moon Knight took arms
to watch over those who link the fire
this has got to be Melina right our
company lost its last proper night
only its Covenant was preserved to this
day
until the time of thy visit
um forms indeed
they are both voice acted by Martha
Macintosh let's go
it's like I played these games a lot May
the Dark Moon watch over thee
that's awesome
I like that I could tell like I could
hear it that's good
all right
I'm just wondering like is she really in
prison like is she just sitting here
and she not get down
like I know there's an invisible wall
but I feel like you could leave
you could Traverse down this way
I mean I don't know
I feel like there she could leave
okay let's go down this way
God why did this is just like bloodborne
why is there always these [ __ ]
all right I did not hit that but we'll
take it
excellent
oh that's the
the painters from Dark Souls 1 and their
armor let's go cool
hold on we're gonna get it we're gonna
be fine
[Music]
okay over here
careful
careful
uh oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
obs
are we live what just happened
whoa that scared me are we live right
now
my OBS said yo what up but we're gonna
we're gonna break and we're gonna
reconnect
are we good
holy [ __ ] I've never seen that before
all right all right all right thank you
thank you
what's the best starting crap class in
Dark Souls probably mercenary
foreign
we need to go back I can't go here
because I'll just have to go down
do I have to make that run again
I should have hit I'm an idiot
I should have hit the other bonfire
that's at the top of the bridge before I
went across the invisible Bridge
son of [ __ ]
yeah OBS was like this jumping puzzle is
way too easy let's destroy his stream
real quick
I just don't know why that happened OBS
is
such an odd program
great to watch AGT while work spreads my
cheeks like a coconut husk
um I'm glad I can make work a little
better
foreign
I set a challenge for myself to fight
Gail every day until Elden ring DLC is
announced
I think you're gonna be fighting Gail
quite a lot
you can listen
to your phone while taking a test
it's pretty poggers wait isn't this good
down here
yeah yeah
glad she got a bigger voice acting part
in Elder ring for sure
not allowed as long as they don't know
how can they not tell
kids got earpods in
foreign
Wake me up inside I can't wake up
wake me up and save me
I know his moveset perfectly so I'm just
enjoying it it is pretty cool
Gail um
I was gonna say has to be one of the
best fights in all of these games
Gail's fight is sick it's a perfect
ending you know
okay what
are you free
here's what I should have done first
and Orlando
this cold
I think he's the best boss
he's pretty [ __ ] cool like no cap
speed running right now
I can't open this what
up silly
what up farty
I'm in trouble
I think I have to go left
how did Palm give go I parried him first
try
easy peasy
uh oh dead giant dead giant alert oh
[Music]
you kill these guys so we can all be sad
okay that might not happen
my sword hit the wall
okay you're dead
you're dead I'm gonna need you to shut
the [ __ ] up
hey
yo mama fat
whoa listen
it was a joke
he was a joke
ill
all right
cool
thanks man
I'm gonna kill you now okay
let's go
I'm doing such a Souls thing right now
where I'm stuck in a corner in iframe
dodging
foreign
damn it
it was actually so good
I was completely stuck in the corner
you like those eye frame dodging those
okay I'm done with my Apple I'm now
moving to a banana
I think I deserved it
I made fun of his mama
although if you guys want the lore that
giant that dead giant right there is
alive in Dark Souls 1.
same spot
kind of sad
I won't cap it's kind of sad
stop it
there is nothing after the banana the
banana is the final part of my breakfast
now that door will be open we're gonna
ignore the bloodborne boss
we're gonna run to Aldridge
foreign
what are the twin blades infused with
your mom's [ __ ]
a sharp gym
just gotta hit the weird growth on his
back
foreign
[Music]
I think that would hit me
or that
can't [ __ ] see dude
get out of my town
we are so [ __ ] strong right now it's
insane
zero deaths
speaking right now is that the
is it the lady
the lady from the church where we fight
the dancer
yup yup yup
please save your soul I'll do whatever
you want grandma
I love you
Homeward back
nah we got this
we got this one flask no problem
hey yo what up is in your
New York her name is Emma please
so tell him what he must be
alone
dead grandma
dead grandma
dead grandma
place the Basin at the Statue of the
beheading night I will I'm gonna go
level up
but I'll be back
dude just like in bloodborne the sky
kind of changes
based on like how far you get in the
game
also the easiest run back obviously
zero deaths
didn't he die to a silver Knight a few
seconds ago I don't know what you're
talking about no
[Music]
that grammar be sus bruh
oh I have a lot of souls guys
foreign
I feel like I should have way more Estus
Flats than I do
I have any shards no I've just actually
been running right past them haven't I
all right here we go
you go grundleberg never does
Hugo grundleberg can't die
I think that's what people are failing
to understand
[ __ ] your boss weapons I have the boss
weapon in my hands
it does not get better than what I have
in my hand
[Music]
still need a chunky boy
I'll give them the coal
it seems like age has passed we're gonna
play sakiro after we beat this game
[Music]
to good use
more than weapons never have foreseen by
the likes of games
it's for a small service
pay my humble respects
remember they be careful
but they be careful
let's put Aldridge up here
[Music]
excellent
boom
boom
so after we beat the princes we're gonna
go do the DLC
August
I don't want to talk to you wait can I
buy a chunk from
other grandma
you have Ash
give other Ash purchase
[Music]
large titties Tower key
no it doesn't look like it nope
um
we could buy the undead Legion armor
that's my favorite armor in the game I'm
gonna get it it's just it's my favorite
action one yes ma'am
looks sick
boom yeah
I put the sauna
let's go looking cool
large extra purpose is the item up the
dragon area the nameless Rye
right
what up Glenn how we doing
okay
let's go fight the dancer
foreign
I've never used chunky armor
what's the best light weapon
are these twin blades considered light
probably not I don't know
sir
stop it
all right dancer time
my character needs to [ __ ] do some
bicep curls dude
my arms look like spaghetti noodles
needs to eat his protein
foreign
I love this fight it's so cool looking
I think we're about to annihilate her
but we'll see
foreign
[Music]
I have banana on my finger
oh she got stuck
foreign
[Music]
damn
I blame it on the banana
[Applause]
What's the title of the stream again
ignore that
ignore
zero deaths
someone before the stream started
commented saying I can never tell when
somebody puts Pro Gamer in the title if
they're being serious or not
like duh I'm being dead ass serious dude
come on bro
foreign
ER I don't want to hear anything else
but Pro Gamer right now because that was
[ __ ] beautiful
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dude
foreign
ER
[Applause]
I'm not gonna lie
when she hits me
my poise is so bad
that I can't move
but Pro gamer Pro Gamer
we got this
it's obviously in the Poise
that's why I like to hear
thank you blue eyed I appreciate you
it seems a little early
it's chill though okay
[Music]
[Music]
man stop
thank you
Pro Gamer Jack who the [ __ ] is Jack
are you cheating on me chat
are you cheating on me
with some streamer named Jack
better not
thanks again blue eyed
first try hitless run
doesn't get better than this
that guy just committed scooter ankle
there's a lot of blood in that in that
statue
hope you guys want some of the weirdest
lore in the game the dragon we're about
to fight oh my God
foreign
visible baby and kills it
dear little ocelot
the mashes it into the ground
ice I guarantee zoly the witch made a
video on it
guaranteed
child of dragons
where can I get another slab I need one
more slab
you a fat boy
Jack would have had zero deaths Jack
would have gave up
you know what he would have done here's
what Jack would have done when he did a
poll on what game we should play next in
sakiro one he would have played sakiro
I've had like six comments saying dude
the hero one why are you playing Dark
Souls 3.
I know where this Shard is
it's right here
right what a square
you know why I didn't
oh
I found the chunk
because I didn't want to play it yet I
wanted to play Dark Souls 3 instead
that's the only reason
I think it's fine
also [ __ ] this area
yeah dude obviously these games are
better because there's three of them and
there's only one sakiro
obviously
that's the only feasible explanation
is way better objective opinion
hey another chunk
opinion
ew
opinion
just kidding you can have an opinion
it's chill
okay I'm gonna go level again
and upgrade my weapon
howdy Aiden
bloodborne's my favorite so far too
I mean I've played all of them I would
say bloodborne is still my favorite like
it's gonna be my favorite
this game's awesome though I think it's
a close second
lit
okay three more chunky boys got it be
careful ready
don't want me work just wondered
how does a banana make me Hyper welcome
home
[ __ ] okay what are we leveling
I really do feel like we need more
endurance
just getting more swings in
big
flame Horizon is getting a remaster
you mean the first one
what
you're not serious right
you guys being dead ass
70
remastered silly and
77700
777
quintillion 777 quadrillion 777 trillion
777777 miss me
miss me I sure did Andrew thank you for
the two dollars and the sevens I
appreciate it
did I not did I not upgrade yeah I did I
did I did upgrade I remember
I did
um so you guys are quite literally
telling me that Horizon zero Dawn is
going to get a remaster before
bloodborne
you know what that means
there is something else going on between
Sony and from software I'm sorry
there is something behind the scenes
that we will not know or understand
these are my favorite weapons
there's something going on bro they've
got some type of beef of some kind
why does bloodborne need a remaster
though it's fine
dog it's 30 frames per second
that's why
just update it for free make it 60 FPS
plays at 30 frames on a PS5
foreign
the witch found out that he is actually
holding an invisible baby
and then when he transitions he slams it
into the ground
forbidden West at this point
for seventy dollars
dragons
also I've been saying if bloodborne
released on PC and Xbox and everything
with a new like coding
like new remaster or remake of some kind
with 60 frames per second I think it
would sell just as good as Elden ring
probably not as good but it would sell
really [ __ ] well
also this fight is not one of my
favorite fights
not one of my faves
already
[Music]
boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
boy
[Music]
get out of here [ __ ]
[Music]
we are so these twin blades are just
ridiculous dude
what level am I 66.
this is base game Brandon
what Jack would have done that guys
would Jack have beaten him first try
bloodborne shall return
I [ __ ] hope so man
oh here they come we're talking about
bloodborne bring out the Bots there we
go
Jack would have switched to zero Dawn
exactly
you know he would have been like oh wow
one of my favorite games ever Horizon
zero Dawn some of the most basic
storytelling of all time
being a little basic ass [ __ ]
I can't wait for DLC or a remaster
of horizon zeroed on
that's so cool
Dark Souls 2 yeah or nah it's not for me
I don't like it
I personally just don't like it
I can see why people do though
okay we gotta go Firelink
yeah Jack would have clicked on the link
spot exactly dude
you guys are getting it
you guys are understanding
take nourishment in these solventless
[ __ ]
22 I think we we need more health
yeah this is fine
Horizon games are pretty good I just
so I got when I got my PS5 I got the
Horizon the New Horizon one
right
that it was like a bundle that came with
it it was the only one I could find
I tried playing it guys
it's [ __ ] boring
the game's boring it just is
I don't like it be careful you can see
why other people would like it
I just find it boring so not for me
foreign
I do not all right let's go fight
pogger's gun deer
I mean I how do I even pull it why
what I mean by storytelling in games
here's what I don't like about some
certain games
when it comes to like Horizon zero Dawn
they
there's so many cut scenes in Horizon
that I feel like I'm just watching a
movie which I don't want to do when I'm
playing a video game to be honest
there's just so many cut scenes of
people talking
and it's always like this weird
conversation that doesn't seem human in
any way shape or form like one person
talks the other person talks one person
talks the other person talks I I know
that seems like yeah that's how people
talk but not really like if you guys
have played The Last of Us
or even the last of us too it's like
actual human conversations does that
make sense
where it does sound like how people
would speak to one another
it's really hard to explain
yeah Witcher 3 does the same thing
for sure
you're talking about my oh you're
talking to your ex yeah
okay okay
thank you
okay
what am I even stuck on
whatever whatever whatever whatever
whatever
dogs
video game Donkey Last of Us video
no idea
I do like video game Donkey though
I saw he made his own Publishing Company
I'm going that way
I'm sure a lot of people have commented
on how like good the writing is in the
last of us or like how good the
conversations are
holy [ __ ]
I'm over it I don't even remember there
being dogs here
oh God
bruh
he said the exact same thing about that
really
well I guess we agree
legit do not remember their Bean dogs
here at all
all right well we lost our souls I'm
just gonna run
doesn't someone spawn here like uh or
invade
maybe not
are you kidding
this area Heats oh [ __ ]
oh I'm not angry that's right okay
goodness
you need a gun deer at this point
not an easy boss people
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
s that we're overpowered right now
I didn't even Parry
which does make that boss really easy
if you can Parry
yep the title is now accurate
we are pogging out
I'm good at buying video game
prisoners chain where's that
just in here
why so dark
I like it dark
what what is the lore of this area it's
just like another version or the real
version
of the Firelink Shrine
she's still here wow it's like in the
future I believe
a lost lamb wandereth in with
in the Bell
well thou should my purpose know
what can this old handmaid provide thee
oh my dude it's artorius's armor
I didn't know that was in here
whoa that is actually really [ __ ]
cool
should we be Artorias
wow
by the key
we can buy the key in the normal area
it's not even that like it's not even
that good
I want to be Artorias let's do it
best not Terry long
we're in the same time frame right now
as Dark Souls 1.
really
well I mean she did just say that uh
the Bell hasn't told like nearly a peep
from the Bell you know
that's [ __ ] dope
how do I increase my uh
do I have to up my endurance
blacksmith hammer
I do look sick though
wait I didn't see where prisoner's chain
is
from gundir's Soul
oh like I can turn it into the
the thingy okay
the kiln
oh I can go back here
there's a secret wall
that I don't know about
who am I hearing right now
all those ashes
other side
wow that wall uh did not
eyes of a fire keeper
that wall just literally popped out of
place it didn't even fade out
the [ __ ]
you let the dogs out
woof
the eyes are for one of the endings can
I give it to my fire keeper
I mean what would make sense is that the
the fire isn't Shrine the fire wasn't
Linked In This wherever we're at right
examine feet of a giant tree
is there anything up here
oh
Jack would have hit the Spy now
there we go
hmm
pickle pee
pump my rump
no pump a rump
no pump a rump
sag
already opened this would have to be in
the future
Jack wouldn't have purchased sartorius's
armor yeah that's why he's [ __ ] lame
dude
that's why he's [ __ ] lame
I Gotta Wear like regular pants
fitting
good
I was doing the skip
all right how the F do I get out of here
wait what
Oh I thought that was something on the
ground
yeah I picked up the coiled sword
oh that's how I get uh unlimited boner
shards right
yeah now I can bone out anytime I
[ __ ] want dude
all right let's go back
it's the pass have you ever talked to
the shrine man and talk to her first
she'll recognize you
if you never talk to the shrine maiden
and talk to her here first she'll
recognize you
okay
I guess that would make sense
you've been streaming a lot lately
I mean I don't really want to make
videos so I feel the need to stream but
I do I've been enjoying streaming a lot
whereas making videos not not as much
let me see if I what I can turn in here
around her
and a black
bad Shimmer within my scene
just as if it's been lazy yesterday
we did all we could to spare the phone
much has happened since
may happen
of what the thin light of these eyes
might reveal
dream of betrayal
things never intended for her again
[Music]
interesting
prisoner's chain
increases Vigor endurance and vitality
but you take more damage so it's radagon
Source seal right should we even get
this
I don't feel like this is going to help
us that much
[Music]
I'm not streaming every day so it's not
often enough I stream a lot
[Music]
it's a good one
no this isn't my first time
uh I would say Dark Souls 3 is a great
beginner Dark Souls it's the first one I
started with
[Music]
all right I'll get it I feel like people
will get mad
treat the fire keeper not with this
courtesy
to link the fire
[Music]
does he not have legs foreign
you won't feel more damage taken okay
he kind of looks like a finger
it's a chain
really does look like a thing
plate of the dark
oneself to the blade of the Dark Moon
Covenant that
that looks like the coolest
okay now where do we go
turn off the in-game music correct the
background sign you can hear music near
the main pathway
cool
get ring of favor
I think we're good
yeah we gotta go to lothric Castle right
I played cyberpunk when it came out
was not uh super happy with it obviously
um we gotta go to
the dancer and just go straight that's
right
create a lightning into pickle p
oh I should have gave her the eyes yeah
we'll come back
we're out of here
it's too much to do too much to see
now what's wrong with hanging the back
street you never know if you won't go
never shine if he won't blow uh hey now
you're a rock star
get your game on go play
God damn right we're gonna do nameless
I'm gonna make sure I'm as strong as I
possibly can
before I do
fish
if you trade you get a very good item
I'll like it what is it
hood of Prayer
um well I am embered up right now Trey
so that could be why
that could be why
uh what the [ __ ]
damn bro
best adult dating site guys best adult
dating site
hidden
is it a click bait title
is it clickbait
or is it just funny
here's another chunk
couldn't remember
you like the twin princess fight
and rip that guy huh Jesus Christ
I'm about to get dropped off
yo
bye bye fatty
should change the sweep title dude best
adult dating website I'm pretty sure I
would get uh
demonetized or banned of some kind
yeah we've been to both of those silly
we beat yorm
another chunky boy we're finding our
chunks now this is good
whoa
the clips
we're getting ganked
go watch the live stream
I have no idea oh God nice
oh man there is a lot of stagger
mechanics in this game bro
a lot where I'm just like can't move at
all
um what was I gonna say I actually don't
remember
I don't remember
work
now I can't heal
fault
no I'm not playing online you guys scare
me
foreign
illusionary wall
dude why so if Dark Souls 3 has a lot of
references to berserk as well
why has nobody really talked about
Reserve
since Elder came out that's the only
time I was ever hearing that
or maybe I just didn't see what people
were talking about before
oh do I get anything cool from the fat
man
can I run this
the answer is no
foreign
that's literally a minus 35k right there
yeah I know where to go guys I just
wanted to see if I could
run it
I am Jake and I did die
how many times have I died zero
ignore what you just saw it's zero
I don't die
if you see you died on the screen it's
not real
you're having a dream
how do you go through there
I feel like a one
no no no no no no no no no
dude [ __ ]
let me go
come on
The Staggering
insane
double the YouTube money you're going to
start doing alternative streams as the
Jack persona
that sounds like double the work
Jack already quit the game for the day
just saying
Jack is my alternate persona
I'm America and Jack is radagon
throw another bomb at me what see what
happens
you about to find out
you gonna find out
you get a sword up your butt
what are the lore implications
um my chat drives me absolutely insane
oh I have to create another persona
I have not had a child with myself yet
we're thinking about it though
I'm over here
these guys do more damage than the
bosses
isn't pale Pine resin good against the
dragon slayer
let's write up her
I guess ain't gonna matter
whoa
tried to actually shake my ass
Jack does not have a dog
that's how sad he is follow your death
fall to your death
foreign
is he on top of the elevator
here we go back up
praise the sun hope your day has gone
better than mine Jake got crushed by a
pallet of block oh
no bones broken I mean that's good that
sucks man I'm sorry to hear that my day
has just started and it's going okay I
appreciate you man
I hope you're okay
no broken bones is poggers
boom
[Music]
yeah do you like have to uh I mean what
happened
is there a
couple of cuts and bruises nice that's
not too bad
we gotta kill these guys first I think
oh I don't want to die
camera
foreign
yeah hope you're okay Rick
easily fall off here
left in on a slow walk past it you know
the rest damn
foreign
you get some time off work
why does this Dragon not care that I'm
just annihilating his toe
just kill the parasite
no this is more fun
they both die
they're hidden something around here
I don't know what I'm hearing down there
but I ain't the only one but
Alden ring feels rushed what the [ __ ]
you're just chilling there man damn
did I send this down okay we're good
uh uh not gonna be easy
but let's see how we do first try
I love this fight
[Applause]
all right good start
that was good that was good
that was good good start
good analysis of the fight
that was good
excellent you could say
okay we want to go here now
it's a little bit faster
or wait is it
now that I think about it do I even need
this elevator that I killed the dragons
yeah that's gotta be a further run
except we have to like get on this
elevator but it is what it is this yeah
I think this is the best
yeah the butterflies make this fight a
little awkward
seven hours straight of Dark Souls 3 I
have punched every wall in my sight IRL
thus resulting in my broken fingers
Bam Bam Bam
that ain't good
y'all gotta be careful
nah this feels faster like that was
pretty quick you just have to wait
the uh the elevator
okay let's try that one again
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
did not mean to jump
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
why are you still alive yeah maybe it's
only two of them
do you like cats I don't mind cats
I'd rather have a dog though you guys
want to see the dumbest thing in the
soul Series so we got a bonfire right
here right
very nice bonfire we like this we like
this
we're gonna run about a hundred yards up
this this stairway
another one
look at that
ever decided this is dumb
foreign okay let's go back
they should have just put one right here
ignore the other one and just have it
right here you can yeah can we see look
you can see the bonfire over there
let's put one here
it's so dumb
all right we are actually flying through
this game right now
we're kind of annihilating the game then
we're gonna get in the DLC and that's
where everything's gonna come into a
standstill okay
that's what's gonna happen
It's Gonna Hurt
but we will get through it
when is Jack coming back would you guys
rather have Jake or Jack
let me know
foreign
I will give her the eyes yes
do I have lightning urns
it does not look like it maybe I can buy
one
you guys want Jack
really
welcome home I should speak there
[Music]
okay what do we need
more endurance
I think that's fine
we'll go for 40 Vigor next
[Music]
are these eyes
the music cut how gracious
ly oh
music
huh
what was the music
you see that oh
my thanks for the
person
not met it is forbidden
these will reveal through a sliver of
light frightful images of betrayal oh a
World Without fire
fashion one is this truly thy wish oh
[ __ ]
what do you guys think
do we wish for a world without Flame or
do we just link the fire again
[Music]
because it's all a vicious cycle that
comes back to this every time
how can you grill without Flame
I say without flame because if if you
know the true lore it's like it's not
even worth it to keep re-lighting the
flame
wish for a world without it
she don't like that
no one else may know this
damn political
Lords to link the fire
and I will blindly tend to the flame
whoa
until the day of thy Grand betrayal
okay I like that
I like that
[Music]
kill me
as it has always been so if I decide to
not betray I kill her
may sound thy peace I mean now that
we're
let me get the tower key and we can do
even more lore
because I believe there are a bunch of
dead fire keepers
in the tower right next to her right
or right next like right up here
no carne asada
that made me think of Chipotle
oh I should have got the lightning iron
Brew
you really want me to get this lightning
huh
you are big on it
forget what's even up here
I know
that there are a bunch of dead fire
Keepers down below
what would a Michelob boss fight be for
you I personally don't think we would
ever fight mikola ever it doesn't make
sense
fire keeper soul
is this a fire keeper
must be
fine patches yeah we killed patches he's
dead
how do I go down below do I just drop
do I gotta roll and [ __ ] oh God what
does this remind you of
yep
I want to jump
foreign
keeper robe and close
yep just a bunch of dead fire keepers
relighting the flame over and over and
over again right
doesn't lead to anything bro
my HP is Never full so [ __ ] that
what did I just get oh this one
increased HP restored with Estes flask
is that is that good
I don't feel like that's really worth it
since we get boners
fine
very sad
20 percent
well I don't ever get hit or die
ignore that
forgot you existed
katana
who rivers of blood
be worth it for endurance fights
uh we won't ever get hit
Ana rivers of blood
sounds good Garrett
so
it's just always
this music now that's sad
what can I do with the fire keeper soul
oh give should I give it to her
hi Jim how are you
River supplies
no
yes
yes doesn't hurt
okay
this is
much like what lies within me
then let it find its own
within my person dude that's fear
we are both fire Keepers how many
references have we found to Elden ring
is now able to heal the dark sigil cool
that's literally fear
heal the dark sigil do I want to do that
is it because I'm dead
I don't know like y'all are like
freaking out about stuff
your Hollow level gets removed
I don't even think I have a hollow level
do I
no I don't because I didn't do the
thingy that's right
I didn't do
uh
y'all
[Music]
welcome home
forgive me if this sounded strange no we
don't give a [ __ ] about Joel show a
World Without fire
vast stretch of
left but is different to what is seen
when strict of vision
in the far distance
sense the presence of tiny flames
like Precious Embers
Left To Us by past Lords linkers of the
fire
could this be what draws me to this
strangely enticing Darkness
do you farewell Hashem one
May thou thy peace discover
May thou thy peace discover now
he's like I'm level 73.
does she not remind you guys very much
of fear and like even the things she
says
okay we need five more chunky boys
which I think we'll find as we go
no okay
rests in thy bosom
[Applause]
[Music]
dress similar otherwise no I know
they're dressed like yeah that makes a
lot of sense too but the thing she says
the things she does
things she wants to do it is all
extremely similar
can someone look up uh
is FIA voice acted by the fire keeper in
Dark Souls 3.
that's where I'm freaking out about it
I think that's what it is
holy damage
foreign
not the same voice actor
okay
you say so
oh yeah don't [ __ ] like
no stop
please please thank you thank you
oh
[ __ ] your table
which is locked
hour within
you guys are very interesting today
okay
thank you
music's already pretty high
imagine showering
disgusting
foreign
certified doctor
I thought this was a ladder I kicked
it don't matter
go
yeah Jack takes showers Jake does not
oh [ __ ]
you want to be more like Jack
lame
imagine
oh
no shower DLC run
when we do the DLC that'll be the new
title
no showering DLC run
we already got the slab we want
foreign
that's a creepy
yeah out of nowhere
that was only a band only a beta debated
baited baited you made it
the lowest one
I'm just playing the game naturally
going through it we'll get what we get
it's okay
that was very close
just pure death
[ __ ] yo
few chunks right there
oh God nope bye-bye
I won't shower till I beat Dark Souls 3.
that's the perfect title
that's that's the that's it
thine hand smell of unshowered Ash
oh
[ __ ] all y'all
shortcut unlocked
sucker my dear hope you show me how to
do the fight I finished Dark Souls 3 a
few days ago
back in time kind of flood this [ __ ]
my dude
only your second time I mean
try more than twice and you'll probably
be okay
uh my dear's hard but
um
once you learn his movements he's not
that bad you're just like baiting out
attacks pretty much
all right
twin Prince's time
yeah I got the shortcut
[Laughter]
I think I could upgrade now
excellent
yeah we'll level
probably be smart
Rusty coin
a little scaly boy
where's this in upgrade too
or a shortcut too
foreign
no Kirby calm down about the [ __ ]
oh this is why they put this bonfire
here
oh that makes a little bit more sense
I mean that's actually a far run
I guess that's the closest thing so why
not
hello I guess
it's a safe run
pickle B
okay
we got some of these
awesome
speak
very well Daddy
farewell my health bar is more than
halfway across the screen now
what
reinforce oh we do need one more
hole
[Music]
y'all go under the bridge now
saying that's where that was right
under here
big figure
My Stream is lagging my kids are
streaming cartoons on the TV those damn
kids
they should be watching my stream not
watching cartoons
there you go there's your lightning urn
I thought you're talking about
hit shards dude
there we go
there we go
no transform
no
in five years I'll let him watch what do
you mean dude I'm so PG I'm such a PG
streamer
obviously
holy [ __ ] I'm literally gonna do this to
make Kirby stop talking about it
fully upgraded twin blades let's go
I think we're good on the bone shards
to be honest
you're not sorry
you would have kept doing it until I did
it
loading times
there we go
is this the only way up here
just a lot of that
everybody's standing at that bonfire
over there no
all right all right pickle pee
oh yeah I could get there from the tower
that's true okay lightning urn leaving
the lightning urn
[Music]
oh nice
that is so not worth it at all
I'll wear it though man for you okay
gosh
cool armor
raise the sun indeed
I'll [ __ ] wear it
is Dark Souls Forge happening anyone no
probably not
although you guys were talking about
some leak
about Dark Souls 4
which I I don't know why they do that
over making another bloodborne
or eldering DLC or something
okay now we'll go fight the twin
princess
we want to go here
they're too young for Dark Souls 3. I
like to sleep too no need for kids
having nightmares
[Music]
uh new from game says originally for but
became its own thing okay
that makes sense
I would love that
now they aren't talking about like it
being
Elden ring right
I think they should just make bloodborne
too at this point
I hope that's what they go for
yeah I really like this fight too
I think we're gonna go
this is gonna go pretty well but we'll
see
oh dear okay Kirby we'll see another
dogged contender
welcome unkindled one
winner of cinders
can you guys believe it's already been
seven months since eleven ring came out
the mantle of Lord interests me none
the fire linking curse
I mean this wouldn't give your kids
nightmares right
enough
now have your rest
foreign
[Music]
get annihilated
Jesus Christ
dear brother
I'm on my way
[Music]
dear brother
[Music]
you were for that is our curse
[Music]
badass
[Music]
very badass
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but
so you only have to kill the other one I
didn't even know that
yeah we are I mean the title makes a lot
of sense now doesn't it
the title really making sense now isn't
it guys
this is what happens when you don't
shower
okay
where are you at there you are
like nourishment from these solvingless
Souls
yeah I think we can
what do you guys want to do first
nameless King in that whole area
or DLC Ash is a very indel what do you
want first
uh the one who convinced lothric to not
leak the fire was probably Ponto
Sullivan
I think it makes sense
yeah we're using super op weapons right
now
nameless King DLC nameless King nameless
nameless nameless nameless nameless okay
let's do that
nameless it is then
it's the easiest way to get there uh
uh actually I go here I can go backwards
right
trying to think
yeah I think this is it
[Music]
aldia was lockedberg's Private mentor
I really wish
that we could see
especially with Elden ring
and all these games
DLC or something that goes on before
everything went to [ __ ]
because we're here where everything goes
to [ __ ]
I would like to see
before everything goes to [ __ ]
that's cool Kirby
but I got the right emo right
you use over here
some type of prequel
would be really nice
I did die to gun deer I don't want to
talk about it
path of the Dragon
this is really cool
got upstand
[Music]
personally I think Elden Ring's first
DLC if they do make DLC is going to be
called the shattering and it'll be like
the events leading up right before the
shattering
told to us all by Nicola's thing like
we'd go with mikola for the most part
or we'll just go to the Badlands and get
that first
it's already called the Badlands no it's
not shut the [ __ ] up it's not even real
we'll see though could be right
it's not confirmed in any way shape or
form
foreign
can we do this run in one try imagine
wait I should hit the bonfire [ __ ] all
right well now we have to
I know the bonfire's there you just
can't get the bonfire with all those
[ __ ] around
foreign
[Music]
holy damage
okay
don't hit me
thank God
[Music]
I
die
bye-i-fi
terrible boss fight
awful
okay Krusty
cannot tell you how many times I died on
that run I'm surprised we got it in one
try
didn't even need the bonfire
didn't even need it
I am gonna go get 40 bigger
the yeah the ax guy that does an absurd
amount of damage
agreed
yeah we died to gun deer and not that
boss just saying
at this point
endurance let's go
farewell 81 81 81.
okay there we go
[Music]
how'd you kill everything except soul of
Cinder
nameless King is absurdly harder than
solo sender
and that's what SOC is
it's Lord of Cinder right I don't even
remember
okay I'll be down here
oh God
full of sensor
you think we're getting Alden Ring's DLC
this year I do not Andre
I don't at all
all right
[ __ ] you
yeah I think we'll get an announcement
at the game awards I think that's true
just like we did when elder ring came
out
for DLC
I think that's all we're gonna get
though
oh these things
and another dragon
ow
what does this remind you
I'll have to uh would you guys like a
stream where we watch the game awards
together
and see if we get an announcement at the
end
[Music]
ding ding
I think that'd be fun oh I couldn't even
see you because you're so naked
that'd be kind of fun
dude nightbot has really come into his
own and just started yelling at people I
love it
this is exactly what we need
it's about
to suggest all right
it could be fun
here we go
would you guys say this is the hardest
fight in the game maybe Gale is
or Frida I think freed is harder than
this
foreign
[Music]
did you just say Eldon ring is
underwhelming graphically
yeah base game hard is true
oh that church fight Kirby yeah it's so
annoying I I find it just annoying it's
not really hard it's just annoying
you can get [ __ ]
all right here we go
I'll do my best
Epic
fighting the camera here boys
get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here
y'all remember what the title's called
right
y'all remember
oh that's so sweet until he just [ __ ]
annihilates it
no kidding nameless Kings calves are
insane
I'd be working my calves to be anything
like him
I couldn't walk on
thick
I honestly
straight up
the camera not locking on pissed me off
so I died because I was mad
that's the only reason though
phase one is extremely unique to
lightning I think he's weak to uh my
blades too
foreign
was only looking at the sword not the
thief
[ __ ] you
foreign
wow
a lack of depth perception is the true
boss
man
you've got a Dodge
through
you gotta Dodge there bud
Dodge
foreign
[Music]
I don't know I don't remember
[Music]
foreign
hello
[Music]
you're so fast
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I dodged
good advice guys on getting good and
dodging I don't know about the advice on
leveling up I think someone said
um
I did the other things I did the Pro
Gamer got good thing
good advice
such an anime scene
so anime
nice
is there anything that we need over here
I don't think so
we're kind of as good as we can get
we're just dumping our levels into decks
at this point
let me run
ornstein's armor
uh we got the good armor there's another
slab just in case we want to do
something later
let's go look
this is pretty cool
whoops dragon slayer spear
oh it brings us all the way back here
did you guys mean that
hey
not dying
ow
oh there it is I've found it
I thought they just walk away they're
like all right
fair enough
yep that's what I'm doing Kirby
you only get 16k from nameless King
or I guess that was his soul
so now we're going to
ashes of ariandel right I think we've
done everything base game
besides Lord of Cinder obviously
right
so I think we have 40 Health we don't
really need to go further than that so
we're just dumping decks
one
why mommy I love you
fire for iron bell
fire for Aryan Dell
okay we are going here
30 endurance
I think if we're beating nameless King
in like three tries or whatever
endurance wise I think we're looking
pretty good but I'll keep an eye out for
that
mother of three shut up Gail take me to
the take me to DLC
what's he doing like is he ready for
something uh from behind you must be I
mean
[Music]
you must be
that my credit score went up let's
[ __ ] go
wrong
Gotta Love an email like that
oh
oh oh oh oh
very upsetty spaghetti
oh
don't mind me didn't mean to fall apart
rent was due
land I need you to show her Flame
a proper flame that will burn the rot
away
truly are ash then it must be fire that
you see
true
how far into this essay are you Krusty
the painting of Ariel
well rotted scrap of it that is
God
take it
to touch it
you guys touch that
you guys go ahead and touch that do you
do that
I think we were taught better yep that's
why you don't touch that [ __ ] chat
guys bent over crying
and says please touch it
I deserve it
[Laughter]
Krusty's gonna get grounded for not
doing his essay
LOL
lovely
ah
okay
have you just arrived
how very unusual
just how long has it been
Rejoice my new friend
for this is a true Haven of the full on
the cold and gentle painted world of
ariandel
quick
is that Max rank max level mindless find
one for yourself
also print asked how his wife is a brain
surgeon
I think it's brain we've all seen
terrible things
but you're safe now
it is
Harry and Dell will make a fine home for
you so go on ahead heart surgeon find
one for yourself
a sweetly rotting bed to lie upon
okay
okay
what are the other fights in this I
don't remember oh there's the one with
the big wolf and the dude
um
this is just that
Frida
whoa
oh there's only those two wow
all right
by uh but Aryan though
I will say sister Frida is quite the
boss
I really like this DLC
it's very interesting
foreign
yeah the lore is cool
Wolfies
[Music]
[Music]
we don't even want to go this way
hold up hold up hold up
uh there's a lot of lore stuff Travis
that you can learn
bad trees bad trees
I think Rings would you guys say ring
city is the better DLC I would ring city
is pretty [ __ ] cool this is this is
nice this is like bloodborny to me right
here
I like it
very stable Bridge
yeah I would say like kind of the area
of ring city is pretty [ __ ] gnarly
dude it's pretty hard
well
you look to be unkindled
no Bell towels
and yet you've slipped into the painting
ah no matter
if you've lost your way
the words of Lady Frida will guide you
now go on inside show respect and listen
carefully you guys like that voice
yeah I agree voodoo
boo-boo
where's our painter lady I want to go
see her
she's not here is she
here's one of the big theories of Elden
ring
that Elden ring is the world that this
girl who's usually here painting creates
not here yet
excuse me
hi Frida welcome to the painted world of
ariandel yo I am Frieda nice to meet you
I have long Stood Beside our blessed
father and the rest kind of boo-boo
seemeth not you think it's bloodborne it
could be too
other missteps which led thee to this
painted world
but thy duty is all and thy Duty lieth
elsewhere
Wednesday
guide thee nonetheless
right ah yes
yes thou should spy rights possess
ours is a is the chance encounter to be
sure
but perhaps it was meant to be let this
be a remembrance of this cold world
thing to help thee bear thy Duty
now children return from Wednesday okay
cross resistance I think comes to place
in the
place in them that alone is cause to
rejoice
so freda's basically telling us get the
[ __ ] out
essentially what she's saying
lady Frida has spoken has she not
then tarry no longer and be gone exactly
bye
that guy's mean
I say fair enough not gonna lie fair
enough
that's a good point
um should I go down this way chat with
the broken ladder or or the broken
bridge or that way
we gotta go that way first right
I'm gonna go down this way
excellent
it's good
it's good
hang on please there we go
doesn't bloodborne refer to the fact the
scourge of the Beast is spread by the
blood
yes
okay here's okay
here's the main theory on all this right
Hideki
nose
that through all of his games there's
going to be things that he pulls from
each game into his other games right
he knows that and he likes to have
meaning
to everything he creates so like the
blood the girl uses blood to paint in
this game so then people can assume like
well maybe that's where bloodborne
started shut up I'm talking chat Bots
get out of here
he knows that
it's why like I mean it's not even
Theory I think this is just like factual
that
um
you know you only go Hollow your
character only goes Hollow when you give
up like when you completely stop playing
so he knows his games are hard he's
saying you know it's the same thing
right
Stan I should have realized he would
have got that my bad I'm usually just
going right at it
so he knows that you can pull from all
these games of the same thing so he's
like purposely connecting all of these
things
to basically have us talk about it in
that way
so it's you guys get what I'm saying he
knows that he's pulling things from
other games to be used in all of his
games
so he likes to have meaning for that
you know
it makes sense to me
so while I don't think that all the
games are literally connected
I think him just having those little
reference points
and a reason for that
is why he does that because obviously
he's gonna pull from his other games to
make new games
right
oh boy oh boy
excellent
just keep going fam just keep swimming
ow
okay
all right let's go fight this boss right
quick
I don't know maybe what I was saying
doesn't make sense
it makes sense to me
I don't think so boo-boo
not like where we can say yeah they're
definitely connected it's just like
pulling references
[Music]
how is this dog alive
this boss sucks okay
[Music]
[Music]
that's good
now we got a big doggy to work with
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it is optional but we want to do all the
bosses as many as we can
that boss did just get very much
grundled
this guy one shot nameless gang
how many times we died in nameless twice
beat him on the third try or something
or try
the only manner weapon is insane
I should go level
I just don't want to lose
these Souls
fear of the church
not one of my favorite boss fights
I died
very well then hey
I've definitely died
yeah let me get endurance to 30. I think
that'll help a lot
burn Champions bones
oh that's the other thing that's right
that's like
you should okay
zero deaths
that's right I don't die I never die I'm
too good at the game to die
if you see that you died on the screen
you're having a dream
it's not real you're in a painted world
that doesn't exist
obviously
uh
could James
probably not but good
what the [ __ ] is on my screen
what just happened
do you all see that
what was that
did I get hacked
scared the [ __ ] out of me
that's a bug when you install mods
I don't have any mods on this game what
is this
what the [ __ ]
is this when I attack things
I have never seen that
have to restart the game
let me attack somebody else
what the [ __ ]
does anyone know what that is I don't
have any mods
in Dark Souls 3 I have mods on Elden
ring
it's when I lock on
it happens to a lot of people that is
weird
yeah it has like it says dummy over
like items
it's interesting
[Applause]
you're right it is when I lock on
what is this
okay it's when I hit an enemy
a restart will fix just a full reset
okay
what does it say it is on Reddit
there used to be hundreds of Reddit
posts every day about that what the [ __ ]
just a reset like this or a full reset
of the game
oh yeah I gotta put out
really common back in the day full reset
all right
hold
okay play can I go pee real quick it's
probably a good time to go pee
I'll be right back I'm gonna go pee BRB
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
we are back
uh screw you guys I'm getting him
free okay let's see if it works
I am locked on
I am attacking we are good
dung pie
CE
if I remember right hi
you can see my mom through the window
mom I can't see the dog okay we're good
that that right there
oh God
for obvious reasons we don't like this
guy
foreign
obvious reasons we do not like that guy
you wrote an essay in 10 minutes Krusty
impressive
waterfowl dance 1.0 oh God we're so far
away
so far away I am running past that guy
he's harder than any boss we've fought
that is very true print
you can get the bonfire after the bridge
no
it's not right there
I gotta go in the house
[Music]
[Applause]
one Nexus ladder
no there isn't okay there might be it
doesn't matter
running past this freak
oh God
we gotta find a somber three Gus
isn't this guy nice over here yep oh
well
there is nothing for long about you
you must be the other Ash I suppose
I am Ash OH
finally you have come
oh wondrous Ash
can we Massimo can you not do that
please don't burn this world away
my lady must see Flame
and you have only to show her
you are ash are you not
yeah we don't really need it it's not
fire that you seek we're fully upgraded
baby
surely you've seen
the rot that afflicts our world
and bury the flame
after we had all made up our minds too
so
grant us one wish
make the tales true
burned this world away
my lady burn it down baby
only
okay
I will
[Applause]
free okay we got one right here
definitely running past this guy as well
this guy right here
how much damage could you possibly do
holy moly
oh God I forgot
foreign
Trump
gameplay
I would say Elden ring
oh God run
run chat I forgot that was such a bait
such a bait
I didn't see it
chill
foreign
you don't see me you don't
get the fence [ __ ] get the fence get the
fence okay
[Applause]
foreign
holy [ __ ]
oh God damn it
I forgot everything man must be caught
every secret must be Unearthed
such is the conceit of the
self-proclaimed seeker of Truth
but in the end and looks like you like
the stomach
to the agony
whoa
isn't there a way to cheese him wait
hold on
I think it's out here is this guy
hey he went back
come on I'm out here
come come
he's like not programmed to be out here
yeah see he'll start backing up
yep
just starts walking
it's giving me my lady
swore enough
unexplained cool
got a cheese to get the dub sometimes
you know what I'm saying
foreign
books
it's our painted lady
yay
that's the one of whom Uncle Gail spoke
the one to show me Flame
that's me tastes good
when this is done may I return
the door is open thanks to thee
it is good
it is good
when this is the door is open thanks
she said something else she's good I
promised Uncle Gail I would okay gotcha
you can't use that yet
stuck on Roth lothric and lorian uh we
fought him about 30 minutes ago if you
want to go see how we did it
I think we beat him first try
go
the bull boss of Dark Souls
cool stuff good stuff
yeah I think I remember what to do
around here
key word is I think
now not a good start
foreign
[Music]
stop following me leave me be
let me get to the tree
and kick the tree
pre-kicked shortcut unlock
in elevator activated
excellent
Looking Good Very poggers in the chat
power in the frozen tundra place
uh
uh with all the Viking dudes
I've never been on this channel but nice
to meet you nice to meet you too
Birmingham
hope you're having a good day welcome
yeah the next shortcut's worth it though
makes everything a lot easier you knock
these trees down
that one that's where we need to go next
not up here but all the way up and
around
all the way up and around
Finn's Fortress do be a [ __ ]
let's keep swimming swimming swimming
knock over the tree knock over the tree
here
doggy do not come in here okay what did
I say
now you're dead
imagine
I am just so angry
I'm mad about that
foreign
so much blood loss build up here
because these little
parts
we gotta hit this tourney thing right
here
boom
that's what we want
how is the best Souls bloodborne or Dark
Souls 3 what
what is your question
is there a secret boss
mean the dude and the big wolf we did we
just fought him like 10 minutes ago
killed him first try
this I I will be very surprised if we
beat sister Frida in one try
it's not gonna happen
right above the wolf dude
I don't know what you're talking about
I truly do not as ashes will be
ever seeking fire
get me out of here
what's behind an illusionary wall
I thought you guys said there were only
two bosses in the steel
foreign
it's not a boss
then why are we doing it
in MPC Invasion nope don't care
yeah I'm not doing it nope
if it were a boss sure but
figured there was not one
at least check it out
nah I'm gonna do this
should this world wither and wrote even
then would ariandel remain our home
leave us be fashion one
sweep all thought of us from thy mind
thy kind always have
now I'm gonna go for it
once again
forward storage ideas
oil
right away
why do I just peek inside the bowl dude
like am I not terrified of this guy
please read it to me please
the flame
flickering once again
I can't see it feel it I love his accent
it's so cool
[Music]
it is only the flame quivering at
misguided Ash
please avert thine eyes
I would snap out these ashes for good
Sam this is such a good fight but it's
so hard
[Music]
[Music]
I do not remember how to fight you
foreign
behind me
foreign
this way
[Music]
you can see it from the snow
that's my bad
foreign
[Music]
not good
[Music]
now it gets hard
ready for the
the scariest scream you've ever heard
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
dudes still sitting on a chair
okay we could have had a way better
phase one for sure
[Music]
this is gonna take a while guys I gotta
remember how to do these stages
I believe this is the only three stage
boss fight in all the games right
[Music]
Gail's not three
could not have been looking at chat
behind me
no stagger huh
fair enough
where is Gail's third face
[Music]
a lightning I mean I would call it two
phases personally
that was way better
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean we will take that every day of
the week
[Music]
Dodge anything dude
[Music]
foreign
damn bro that stage three is [ __ ]
crazy I don't remember which ones I can
attack and which I can't
[Applause]
we couldn't have had a better stage too
either
let's keep going
[Music]
that's cheap I literally can't attack
her
over here
foreign
what is she doing
what is that [ __ ] from when style
games for that is thy place of belonging
I have never seen her do that ever
what the f
she's like I'm doing this attack no
matter what
she did like six forward steps
he usually does like one or two on that
grab attack and then
he quits because it didn't work
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ] delay dude
[Music]
what's gonna get me it's like fighting
morgot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dude
where is my
this is bad
leave me alone Karina
thank you
Gale can be used in this fight really
good
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it don't matter actually
[Music]
[Music]
he's still going she did not stop
attacking even even after I was dead
oh cool I want to use Gale it's kind of
kind of dope
[Applause]
oh I don't even have to be embered to
use them
is that that was there
okay why not
yeah I love this fight it's just
extremely difficult and I don't have
enough flasks I need to like not get hit
in the first or second stage
that attacks really annoying
foreign
big combos
there we go nice
oh so now he comes in that's that's
pretty cool
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
no healing
[Music]
is that radagon's rings of light what
the [ __ ]
the way of the white Corona
can I like hit her here
Gail
oh that hurts
huh
[Music]
that seemed weird
[Music]
except
no Gail
foreign
well that didn't help that much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
nice
that was [ __ ] clean dude
[Music]
I don't know where she is
[Music]
yo what up Tom
all right could have killed her there
[Music]
not what I wanted to do
let's go bro
I poured one out for Gail Tom thank you
bro
thank you
let's go
why do I not remember there being two
bonfires here
they're actually two bonfires here
all right GG I love that fight
you know you can Parry her I mean I
don't have a Perry item man
what
oh this is the DLC that's right that's
how we get to the ring City
through
let's go level and then we'll do that
we beat the this DLC pretty quickly ring
City
's a lot
for sure
[Music]
well very what the heck take nourishment
from these sovereignless [ __ ]
I want to get to 30 endurance and then
we'll just pour it into decks farewell
fashion one
you can Parry with the shield okay
that's great you can do that in your
playthrough
we clearly did just fine
okay
we have Pawn tips right eye
yep we did Arch Dragon Peak
I think bloodborne's my favorite still
random
foreign
can was the last But Here We Go Again
what is it you want from this old
Stoneham tag
I have nothing for you not a smithereen
I just like to stand here and take in a
view
I have business with you
well love came out of nowhere that's
what I'm saying you'll think an Old
Stone armed hack would be brimming with
goodies
I have none of that not a smithering
I mean you have a pretty cool great
sword other than that you're pretty
useless keep your Marvels intact love
at least until I lose mine
I like her
take the plunge absolutely
that's right we don't get hurt here do
we
if we land in the ash
he'll earn for a surprise no that seems
mean
I don't want to be mean
wow [ __ ] oh God
okay I forgot that's what happens oh
[ __ ] let me go what are you doing to me
he's sucking my dick what the [ __ ] ew
get me out of here
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh man this game this this DLC really
goes goes hard right away
nope
nope oh
let's not save them
excellent wait I can go up there
let me go [ __ ]
let me [ __ ] dude man
ow
all right I'll kill her
strange little lad you are
what on Earth do you see me
foreign
maybe I'll get to see an angel
old woman's ashes
well that didn't seem worth it now I
feel like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
why did we do this
back down we go
we out of here get me out of here
scale
the sound that thing makes scary
you gotta talk to our boy
[Music]
no
[Applause]
go away
I hate the shield once
great timing
that's fair just getting sniped
a couple of chunky boys thanks for the
help oh
look at you
you've got your head screwed on correct
oh that's patches
kindred spirit on this God's forsaken
Crag maybe pull me lap
I can't remember my real name so
let's just go with that I have a feeling
we're going to make a fabulous team
oh it's definitely his voices
you'll see
okay ah
in all honesty there's something I
should tell he's gone a bit Hollow I'm
a hollow
oh [ __ ]
I try to play it off
but I haven't a clue about my past
who I was or what I live for
not even my own blessed name that's why
I've come here searching for the purging
Monument
said to be in the ringed city where the
pygmies who found the Dark Soul at the
dawn of fire resign all I can say is
those little Stones aren't doing much to
help me remember anymore
it's the long and short of it so if I
completely forget who you are
don't be Roth with me come on what else
can I say I'm a bloody Hollow For
Heaven's Sake
[Laughter]
why is he like aware that he's going
Hollow
we're here
[ __ ]
excellent I love that
how can you be aware that you have no
memory
I've always found that weird like how do
you know you don't have memory
thank you
okay do I plunge down on this guy or
like what am I doing here
okay I love ass thank you for that
I hate it here I hate it here
this DLC is so [ __ ] hard
[Music]
uh she's still dead
hi chimpanzee
if you have amnesia you know
I mean wouldn't you not know
oh I [ __ ] up didn't I
we good we good
foreign
God those are terrified
foreign
[Music]
intelligent but no sense of identity
right
I'm wondering is like how do you even
well I guess it does make sense
and thank you Tom
with like if you had Amnesia how would
you know that you well yeah I guess
you'd be like I know I exist
but how do I know
you just don't know your identity you
don't know who you are
right
or like what happened before that'd be
really weird oh
I know that'd be really really weird
great to see you still in one piece
God I can see why they call this the
Drake Heap at the World's End mangled
remnants from every age and every land
it actually sort of lends Credence to
the old rumors that the ringed City
rests below it all
uh don't mind me
you needn't worry yourself with this
nonsense I just wanted to tell someone
I'm sick of old Hunty
I should stay quiet all Humpty's dead
I'll make it up to you
by letting you in on a secret of sorts
passed here you'll find the remains of a
giant Earthen Tower half submerged in a
poisonous swamp not a very nice place to
visit only
this precious treasure in the thick of
this world I didn't have any use for it
you see so sorry I I left the whole
package behind if I get the chance I
could go fetch it for you
if that's too long to wait
go NAB it for yourself I Know Who You
Are
a righteous Warrior
yes
with a solemn duty to boot well grab
that treasure Dark Souls 2 what a duty
as any
past here
well okay
so I have to grab something from the
swamp
I believe so crusty
foreign
things are terrifying
[Music]
um
I'm scared
what am I grabbing from the swamp
how do I get there where am I
get to the cave
foreign
my spot
I already have a slab I have to get him
a slab
[Music]
foreign
okay I found it I found it
little Goombas
out of here what
he tried to death me the [ __ ]
okay do we know exactly where I'm
looking
for this item
this somewhere in here
you don't see me
like do I have to go up the tree or is
it down here somewhere
in the caves
[ __ ]
is it back here
[Music]
yeah
sniper dude okay that's gotta be it
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
what kind of Sword is that sir
oh son of a [ __ ]
foreign
's up here
dude what are you kidding
we already grabbed the slab why you keep
yelling at me
oh I have to go all this way can I just
give it to him
oh
look at you okay cool you found the
treasure
crashing just bashing
you'll make good use of it I'm sure
to you
huh interesting so much to speak of but
uh Bottoms Up To The Greatest Warrior
there is
this really is a drag Heap at the
World's End mangled remnants from every
age and every land
it actually sort of lends Credence to
the old rumors
that the ringed City rests below it all
right
[Applause]
all right
oh God
said the middle root there is a there's
already a middle root
great thanks for the seven months
appreciate it man
foreign
foreign
just trying to live right now
okay
uh what did you ask Trey
what is the record number of YouTube
Watchers
no twitch doesn't have well twitch has
different Bots actually
um
but not like this
I have no idea I don't know what my view
count is ever
I just kind of re-chat
dude that is absolutely insane
holy crap
why do they do so much damage
out of nowhere
I guess I can put on the ring
what does it do
HP stamina and maximum equip load that
sounds good
Fallen foes yield more souls boost
attacks when HP is full
I think we just do this
I definitely don't need magic we're fine
this just
annoying
180 currently eight
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
bosses easier or the same hold on let me
get past this damn area
so we don't need the chainring
I swear to God
oh yeah no we do not want this
let me remains he's boost attacks on HP
is full
I mean
absorb HP from each defeated foe
like that
this one
oh oh this is the Angel yeah
there now it's dead
excellent
okay
questions
okay so let me get past here
why am I fat rolling oh probably because
I took off the ring huh
oh [ __ ]
foreign
I'm just gonna put it back on for now
get me out of this area
okay
foreign
I like the shield
I definitely don't want to increase my
damage taken
might throw this on and then
change my pants
change these as well
still fat rolling Jesus Christ
just gotta up that stamina dude
I want to wear these
yeah I'll have to take it off
that'll work for now
time to take a Plunge
yep
I think it comes from endurance Gizmo
oh
come on
it's not good
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is that a nuke
oh God
I thought I could say
I don't think I've ever seen that before
I don't think I've ever seen that attack
before that was cool
I think I needed to hit him before he
did that
also stage one
did not go super well
try that again
Furby are you just turning into a back
seat or is that what you're doing now
because you're doing a lot of it I'll
tell you what
foreign
foreign
foreign
well
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
why is it later in my streams every
single stream you guys get more and more
progressively backseaty
clearly we're fine
calm down
do this do that do this do this
get up
thank you
I will ask you if I need help
I promise
it's every stream though I gotta bring
it up now
I'm not talking to everybody I'm talking
to certain people and you know who you
are
okay
foreign
we can beat the game a thousand percent
we love you don't die Dingus gets
supplied
what do you mean get supplied we're good
thank you for the two dollars
but I'm gonna tell you guys right now
sometimes
I'm not gonna do what you want me to do
okay
so slow your roll
that's what having a hyper fixation on
these games
you can still stop yourself from doing
those things
and you know it
you know it I know it everybody knows it
you can stop yourself from typing and
pressing enter
you can you can do it I know you can
if I need help I will ask
I think it's 99 overall doobie just like
all the other games
Epic
I really wish we could explore more of
this city
because it's so [ __ ] cool
but you can only go down a really linear
path of it
our friends
all right
how do you think of this guy got here
what a nerd
ring City baby ring City
let's go
most of it's sealed
I know I just wish we could explore it
be fair using the most OP build in the
game
that was the whole point
why wouldn't I use this build
yay
lizard
go
uh should I kill this guy or does it
like not even really matter that much
boom
box
I didn't I was gonna fall to my death
man
I wanted to fall down so I could heal
and come back but I think that fall
would have killed me
so close
so far
you will never reach the banana if you
do not have the courage to climb Monk
is that a quote from monkey
I appreciate you
thank you man
thank you thank you
we have to go this way
I want to kill the guy
a few archers
oh
okay
keep keep that
[Music]
there we go
no I killed him
you can't shoot at me
that was very inspirational one
I'm very inspirational
hello
these guys look death blighted
okay let's go down here
might be able to beat the game today
guys
many of us oh geez
forsaken I forgot about you dying kind
God behold this city
we are Kindred but like two eyes which
gaze upon the other
fear not the dark my friend
and let the feast begin that's great
good for you
that's that's great
one
was a wayfaring night on an endless
forbidden search only the abyss granted
closure if not reunion with his beloved
fear not the dark my friend
and let the feast begin
did I kill this guy because he jump
scared me
or nah
it's talking about Artorias
true
many of us are by the I speak of thine
behold this city
and let the feast
can I kill him do people have said yes
[ __ ] it
that's
what I remember now
[ __ ] you
I don't like him I don't like you either
this city
[Applause]
is a death trap
hope I can finish my homework before you
finish your stream we'll see
I think it's possible
whoa
this is how we have the
the church
we have the church fight
we've got Gail
and then Lord of Cinder right
I think that's it
I think we're good
oh in midir yep we're definitely gonna
fight him a deer
yep yep yep
you oh no backs
[Music]
[Applause]
so four bosses
oh a hollow gem that sounds cool I think
it's awful though not fighting these
guys [ __ ] that [ __ ]
speed run time
Turtle Boy
no I want to land on that okay
I wanted to land on the chandelier
how far back are we okay not that far
actually
I didn't jump
no stab me stab
I just got ring city [ __ ] ring ring
city [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
keeps trying to grab me that damn turtle
it's like bloodborne speak Thee the name
of God thine own God if that can't
recall
uh
do I just say Gwen
yeah I guess ah then that's not
forgotten perhaps is why we may Converse
I am known as Shira
servant to the princess philiana
I'm scared of the church sorry
I'll be back
oh this is gonna suck huh
these little buggy boys away from me
oh God not again
there we go
I already kill you
I shall partake
okay we got that
ow
ew he just pooped all over me
no you shall not partake
Zoli the witch is in this city what
really
where
I didn't know her name came off of this
game or no it came but there's a witch
like her and
Dark Souls 2.
ignore that very tall man
he's here as well
yeah I'm ignoring him he can he can pay
all the attention he wants to me but I
am ignoring him
only and completely ignored
he's around
go your Humanity oh I remember how to do
that it you have to like turn into a
Humanity or something
I don't remember exactly how to do that
but I remember seeing it
I'm just trying to beat the game
there he is boys
my dear
a white branch in the swamp
that's the wrong one
I thought that's where you jump
I thought that's where you jump
it was not where you jump
I was incorrect
yeah would you guys jump there or get
burned alive what's your choice
foreign
there that kind of sucks
or was there a little thing to the right
[ __ ] you
I didn't notice anything to the right
whoopsy doodle we're good we're oh
we're fine I'm fine
did I feel like they had this guy
I'm here this Invasion
or actually he's got a little questline
in the main game
I was gonna say like they don't ever use
them very much
here we go
blindfold mask
this is actually kind of like the sewers
in Landell that's a good uh
good comparison
he lost his Maiden
we've all lost their Maiden at one point
or another haven't we oh I'm back at
where I started got it
foreign
I don't know what that is
I've heard of it is it good
Mario movie Pulp poster what
guys are all over the place right now
where do I
where to go
little indie game
there
huh
interesting
James I think I'd rather jump off
I rather commit scooter ankle
why am I lost
nothing in here
can you go back this way
no no shot
why is this so confusing
so drop down
that's where we started oh I can just do
this there we go
I thought I couldn't go this way
I would have made everything
easier
question
not a finger
chokes on you I'm into it okay
excellent
yeah I'd rather not hang out with uh oh
[ __ ]
excellent
but it doesn't come out what
oh
ring of the evil eye three huh
damn
not gonna help us out a ton
but that is a good ring
a very poggers ring
[Music]
what what what
I just got [ __ ] carried and visceral
bruh
he's just holding up his sword how do
you whatever
bro
I did I did get parried
did do that
gotta knock him off the bridge
foreign
he looks so cool
Howie
[ __ ]
nice
bye-bye [ __ ]
are you guys ready for me to piss people
off
wow that's the Madeira fight you guys
were talking about that's so easy why'd
you guys say that was hard
people with no social awareness will be
like they studied
it's not even the real that's right
goodness
it's starting to be the real fight
you're using overpowered weapons
oh damn
Turtle
okay stop it
thank you
fertile you're being obnoxious
you're being obnoxious
there we go
lightning Arrow
come on Jake what are you even talking
about you know what I'm talking about
it's not even the real fights to see
bucka
it's not even real
hurry
foreign
[Music]
excellent
or actually I should go level and then
you guys won't fight my dear
first
yeah we probably should
foreign
yes I'll get the item
well very well
nourishment in the sovereign-less
[ __ ]
now the music changed when I gave her
the fire keeper her eyes and we are
going to betray
the
lighting of the flame
because it's trash
but I gave her her eyes that's why
oh that's medir right there yeah
a little entrance
go
get that item later
grant us eyes grant us eyes
spirit
this does kind of look like it's it was
just thrown in here yeah
this weird-ass ladder
I would say bloodborne's harder Joey
this game can be hard though
he is
yeah I really enjoy this fight
if I can remember how to do it
[Music]
foreign
attacks currently
it's bad
not going well
[Music]
fighting the camera right now
let's try that again
let's try that again because that was
just bad all that was just not good
I'm on the wrong side aren't I [ __ ]
[Music]
I think medir's a great fight I like the
fight
um I just didn't remember
what the [ __ ] he was doing or like what
his attacks are
yep
yes guys I've beaten this game I have 2
000 hours in this game guys
haven't played in years
what's up
foreign
oh my God
[Music]
normal [ __ ]
I can't remember how to bait out attacks
at all
that was weird
foreign
[Music]
stage two [ __ ]
I have no idea my friend
I think all the weapons in this game are
viable
just the ones I'm using right now are
pretty nuts
Yeet we go again and try to delete
[Music]
oh my God this couldn't be worse
foreign
camera keeps like making me not walk on
[Music]
I'm totally in the dark now I don't
stage two very much
it's good
oh damn
fears of the church
nice dude
that visceral did a ton of damage holy
crap he just didn't even do the
the laser attack that was interesting
full of dark eater my dear that is lit
all right
we will take uh the small amount of luck
that went into that with him not doing
the big attack
but that visceral pretty much finishes
him
[Music]
three more bosses
Gail's gonna be hard
farewell
favorite boss is Abyss Watchers what
about you I would say Gail I think Gail
uh okay so we can go
not here
City inner wall
[Music]
guaranteed stagger at thirty percent
okay
okay yeah I don't think my dear is
actually all that hard
however he can he can end your day real
quick for sure
nope this is the wrong place
oh
I guess it's here
top three bosses from this game Gail
I really like Abyss Watchers I think
that fight's awesome
um
I think Frida is a great fight too
for what it is
my dear's sick too
I'm trying to think of all the bosses
um I don't know if this is a hot take or
not but I think the dragon slayer fight
is sick the one on the bridge I love
that fight
but I would say like the most next most
memorable one would be nameless King
right
I'd say nameless King
get up here
I don't really care about the item [ __ ]
it let's beat the bosses
yeah I would say nameless King has gotta
be a top three
at least for me
oh I did not mean to skip that I was
just trying to open the door
Point princes it's definitely a top five
sure for sure
I hate this fight this fight is garbage
in my opinion
ownership security at all
that sounds
elbows back backstab
Goldie's back
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
foreign
oh my God I hate you
[Music]
foreign
I hate you so much
foreign
this [ __ ] guy
[Music]
moonvale just saying
[Music]
thank you for doing that in one Bell
swoop
thank God we did that first try because
that fight can be so annoying
yeah that was kind of like waterfowl as
well good point
yep get the [ __ ] out of here nerd
it's Gale time boys it's Gale time
let me go level real quick I don't know
if we can actually go back
I do like one of the best features in
Elden ring is that you can level up from
anywhere
instead of having to go back like this
yeah of the chat well
then
keep going we're almost there people
May the Flames guide thy Buzzy let's go
spiritual feeling or
Dark Souls 1 was like that man
Dark Souls 1 was ahead of its time huh
uh you get fast travel later in the game
but you
need a few more boss fights Gail and the
soul of Cinder I will say we're going to
annihilate the solo sender it won't even
be close
so
this is kind of the last boss
so [ __ ] pretty
she's asleep
you have to level up the doll at the
doll yeah
in bloodborne
I broke her egg
soul of sender is extremely easy I I
think compared to Gail
all opinions all preference
the [ __ ] did you do to my egg man
she's like what what why hello I was
just sleeping dude why did you do that
foreign
get nuked honestly
I have to pee again
foreign
capital city
interesting
so many say like they used a lot of the
same ideas in Elder ring for so many
things and then just kind of changed it
up a little bit I'm gonna go pee real
quick before we start fighting Gail
I'll be right back
hello
okay
okay
hey it's booted what up
I do pee out of my wiener
look at my health bar what the [ __ ]
okay
time for my favorite fight
really I know
help me race the Red Hood is come to eat
us to eat our Dark Souls he said the
name of the game he said the thing
he's just been dragging himself along
here for a while
this is so awesome
do you not pee out of your mouth
no
is that the other half of his body
oh that's a bunch of bodies
pretty much Artorias 2.0 very true
oh they're pygmy Lords
what still here
still here
that thing your Dark Soul
s this is my favorite boss in this game
for sure
great OST great boss fight mechanics
just great fight
foreign
foreign
foreign
there we go
[Music]
that's where it gets real
he only does this cut scene once right
[Music]
foreign
s every time
I believe he does this oh he does the
intro once I don't remember him doing
this every time
badass
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
I got greedy
[Music]
foreign
not bad though not bad for a first try
[Music]
I think he runs after me
second try
foreign
oh [ __ ]
no no [ __ ] all right I thought he was
not gonna attack her
not not good not good
bad attempt
[Music]
actually I think these are zero
[Music]
see
he's getting like caught in the hill
down here
[Music]
thank you
no
[Applause]
early second phase huh okay you guys
were right
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
G [ __ ] G dude
GG
Pro Gamer comes out
Pro Gamer came out
g g
guys there's one more boss to do
the title is proven correct yet again
it's time
farewell passion one
thank you Mommy
one
more boss
turn oh I have to be right here
turn the princes to their throne
and she should walk to the middle yep
very cool
it is time
the five Lords sit there five
all thanks to thee most worthy of Lords
that's me Ashen one
with the Lord says thy Witness
and thy
name's coiled sword
and let the Lord's Embers acknowledge
thee
was their true heir
true Lord
fit to link the fire
which is not what we're gonna do
if thine heart should bend
kill me
and strip these eyes from my person
I will return as the fire keeper I once
was
as it has always been
farewell Ashen one
May thou thy peace discover
let's do it
this cutscene is really cool
Noble Lords of Cinder
the fire fades
rip that guy
and the Lords go without Thrones
Surrender Your fires
to the true air
we did all that for this huh
they get sprinkled with some ash
let him Grant death
to the old gods of lordran
deliverers of the first Flame
okay
one more boss
freaking sick
foreign
we beat both versions of gun deer sir
now now
okay okay not good
leave me alone
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this helps but I'm doing it
[Music]
damn it
[Music]
that has kicked me twice
foreign
yeah I'm dead that's a Rippy dippy dude
[Music]
I remember thinking he was so easy back
in the day God damn he is ruthless
foreign
DLC next I'll get right on that man
I'll get right on that there Martin
I thought that was a summon
I did get gwinned huh are we really
gonna beat this game with eight Flats at
plus six
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what
okay
[Music]
right here
[Music]
foreign
G [ __ ] G
game
[Music]
that's game
but we aren't gonna link the fire
are we
and the fire keeper have a plan
betray the fire
let's end this vicious cycle
let the flame die
should I kill her
did I get her did I take it for me
I'm gonna do it if I have the option
I'm gonna let my intrusive thoughts win
oh you guys are gonna be mad the first
flame quickly fades
Darkness will shortly settle
he
but one day
tiny Flames will dance across the
darkness
I hate the way you kill her it's gonna
it's just gonna make you guys sad like
Embers linked by Lord's past
give me my character give it to me
give me my character
there it is
this is my Flame
mine
give it to me
nameless a cursed Undead
unfit even to be Cinder
and so it is
that Ash seeketh Embers
yes I am a heartless
ruthless
businessman
ladies and gentlemen that is dark souls
3.
[Music]
took us two days
Pro Gamer absolutely destroys Dark Souls
3.
[Music]
we will be starting sakiro yes we will
next stream
GG well played chat GT well played
[Music]
so after we played bloodborne right
before this
[Music]
um I would say I prefer bloodborne over
Dark Souls 3.
Dark Souls 3 holds a very special place
in my heart because it was my first ever
Dark Souls game or it was my first ever
Souls game
I think I just like the overall
atmosphere and aesthetic in combat
of bloodborne a little bit more
but this game's incredible
[Music]
for me it's a little bit behind
bloodborne
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a boss that heals yourself all
the time in bloodborne where
we're gonna play Sakira next
as the title was accurate please hit the
like button
for accurate titles
they may be clickbait
but
I think I proved it to be so
Joey you have a lot of really you have a
lot of opinions don't you you just throw
them all out there
I know I will never understand people
who say sakiro isn't a Souls game that
makes no sense to me at all
foreign
[Music]
yes she can heal but she doesn't spam it
dude I don't know
that's like five percent of that game I
don't yeah you haven't even played it
enough
not even close
it's like barely another game
[Music]
speak abruptly ends
I'm gonna say no for now I just can't
hear myself think with all that music
[Music]
the hero barely qualifies as Souls like
this makes no sense to me it's made by
the same company made by the same
director with all the same core
mechanics just different combat
this whatever you can think what you
think I guess
I can still say your opinion's dumb
but
you can have it
no RGB RV
RPG mechanics
that's fine leveling is different sure
isn't a Souls game due to no leveling I
okay
the only thing I have to say to that is
made by same director same company
same core of all of it boss fights
things like that
um
yeah that's it it's a Souls like game
it's not an RPG it's different from the
other games sure
but it is a part of the same
collectiveness
it has the same Soul it has the same
direction
it's all you know
but whatever it doesn't even matter
I think when you say Souls like or a
Souls game sakiro comes into that
conversation obviously
I've never played armored Core
[Music]
didn't those come out before seoul's
games were even a thing
so
yeah here's the thing I know we throw
our opinions out there about [ __ ]
everything
you know is it a Soul's like is the is
this Boss s tier whatever whatever right
we just throw our opinions out there
like it's [ __ ] like whatever it's
nothing
I'm who who cares
you know what I'm saying I just you know
I wonder if there was a time where
people didn't just voice their opinion
everywhere
you know I think that was probably
before the internet
where now everyone can just like put
their opinion out there about everything
all the time
no matter what
I'll definitely check out lives of P
for sure Liza P looks really cool
I saw uh the footage of it it looks cool
I would say bloodborne's combat is very
different too Joey but I still call it a
Soul's like
there's so many mechanics that are you
just like Souls games it is definitely a
souls-like game it's I think it's
ridiculous of people saying that it's
not
yes it's different
it still has the same core elements
I would say Neo is a souls-like for sure
just like uh
thymesia is a Soul's like
you know
I don't know I think this debate's
ridiculous just like with people
gatekeeping as well oh man
like you know if you use summons for a
boss they'll say you didn't actually
fight the boss
there I mean I swear it's like 50 of
people agree and disagree on that just
absolutely like
ridiculous to me
[Music]
but of course you know it's a Souls game
so people are gonna you know voice their
opinions about everything
[Music]
oh
yeah we beat the game Anna
yeah
that's a good way to put it kill it's
like they all have different flavors
they all have different flavors but they
all have the same soul
I mean like think about it when like
with Elden ring especially because
eldering sold so many more copies and
became like mainstream to everybody you
know all those people who really don't
understand Souls games or like
haven't played the other games
just don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about and they just start
well I beat the boss with no without an
overpowered weapon or I didn't use it
without a summon
so I'm better and I you know I did it
and you didn't
you know
I think it's well over 12 million now
I think that was in the first like week
or two it sold 12 million
foreign
Y is harder with summons it just doesn't
matter like if you like the fight with
summons if you don't like the fight with
summons if you like to use XYZ weapon
XYZ spell it doesn't matter
you know people play the game you're
gonna beat it however the [ __ ] you want
doesn't matter
right Nick
yes we just did all the DLC and we beat
the last boss
[Music]
I personally feel like it's fine to use
summons they exist for a reason but if
you go ahead and say a boss is easy when
you used a mimic tier in rivers of blood
then your opinion kind of doesn't count
[Music]
I think what they're saying Joey is the
boss was easy
with mimic Tyrion rivers of blood they
can still have that opinion
they still played the game
you can say that and be like well use
River's blood and mimicked here
but you know good on you for beating the
boss
right
uh they cheesed it
right
rivers of blood is an overpowered weapon
or was at the time and then using
summons like a mimic tier was like
strangely overpowered
like way too overpowered
um
it's cheesing they cheesed it whereas if
you just you know
Dodge and use like a a normal weapon and
played it normally I guess normal quote
unquote
then
you just played it normally
I don't think anything makes a run
invalid
eat the game
like the first time I fee I beat the
fire giant I had him fall up a cliff and
he died
whenever that glitch was in existence I
had so much fun doing that and I I did
that all the way through
now did I really beat the fire giant not
really
but I still beat the game doesn't make
my run invalid
it's just fun
I had a good time
so that's what I'm saying what like what
was I talking about the beginning of
this conversation
like what you're getting upset with Joey
is like oh your opinion you're you're
upset about their opinion of a boss
being easy
because of how they beat the boss right
and what I'm saying
is who
cares
[Music]
you know what I mean
it does not matter
[Music]
so when people get all like upset
it's just like weird I don't know
it's a video game
foreign
I man I don't I you're all over the
place
I beat the game with the lights off
right
[Music]
I just think Joey's one of those people
like one of the people we're talking
about where he is very about his own
experience and doesn't think of other
people
which is fine but it's just when people
like talk like Joey does that it's like
kind of annoying
and then he throws in a lull excellent
I mean I could just tell like based on
how you've been talking for the last
like two and a half hours
I beat the game using rivers of blood my
opinion on it isn't valid no
[Music]
your opinion's fine you just like that's
just what I'm saying who like I don't
know
opinions dude they're just all over the
place
I beat Elder ring by deleting the game
perfect
good
honestly I haven't even played Alden
ring in
two weeks I think
I haven't even touched it
some of the souls players think their
run is more validated because they did a
personal challenge or something if I
beat the game I beat the game whatever
so that's exactly I agree
it it's kind of the way you say it Joey
which I think is like the problem with
like uh
with that like this entire discussion
and not just our discussion that we're
having right now but like the overall
discussion by the souls community of
people gatekeeping like valid or invalid
runs or having opinions on [ __ ]
[Music]
I agree that using like rivers of blood
makes a boss or the game easier it's
kind of like you're cheesing it
but it doesn't matter
it just doesn't
the fact that you even bring up like oh
you use rivers of blood well I used a
dagger whatever as an example
that is what's annoying
that right there just even bringing it
up
is
you know
odd
it's like you have to wanna like people
have to one-up the other
I agree to him I just I don't get it
myself
isn't in the Cocoon true
I think my second playthrough I used
rivers of blood the entire game
that was my most I had the most fun
using rivers of blood for me personally
what level did I end the game at
actually
99 one off of 100.
let's just make it 100.
oh all these are even the DLC a thousand
percent
course
level 100
May thou thy peace
[Music]
I hit him with my swords Travis
I did that
[Music]
who's in the Cocoon I don't know but I
don't think it's Michelob
we'll find out it probably is
I have a theory it's not
why can't we enjoy the game and not
one-up each other every single time
let's just enjoy the game that's that's
mostly what I'm saying
it's just the fact that people bring it
up
and
try to one up
another player
by saying like their opinion isn't valid
of a boss being easy XYZ because they
used a certain build
I bet that like the entire conversation
changes if they say oh I found Melania
to be easy because I use XYZ build
you see the difference in the words that
I'm saying
like having the social awareness to say
different words that mean something else
in the same context
I found this boss easy what bought what
build did you use oh I bet that was
really difficult
[Music]
it could it could totally flip
if people use the right words in the
language
but instead they
are dicks about it it's weird
guys should I ban Joey or not like this
guy is just [ __ ] annoying the [ __ ]
out of me all day dude with your weird
ass comments man on descending lecture
that's what you got out of this
Jesus Christ
get some social awareness man just awful
this is exactly what I'm talking about
I'm Banning them I'm over it
[ __ ] man condescending lecture
I banned him
that they're very rare people like that
but dude they come out
in these games
not trashing anybody just an annoying
kid
we're gonna play uh if I I think I'll
stream tomorrow
yeah we beat the whole game pastor
[Music]
did you use rivers of blood to ban them
or a mimic tier your band is less valid
and your opinion doesn't count
exactly
yeah I'll end the stream soon I'm just
talking to chat right now
some guy named Joey I don't think I've
seen him in chat except for today
but
uh I tried Dark Souls 2 and I hate it
I'm just not gonna play it it's just not
for me
not for me
I mean he said sakiro isn't a Dark Souls
isn't a Souls game because there's not
there's a different leveling
which
okay
and then he's like dude that's my
opinion I'm like sure I can still say
your opinion sucks
if you used a certain weapon
yeah your opinion doesn't really matter
good opinion
I don't know dude
why why guys stop stop stop stop no
stop it
have a good one Taryn
it's because I banned him Garrett
I banned him so he's not here opinion on
opinions
I mean I'm trying to use my words
carefully because that's like the I
think the whole Crux of the issue
is people just like
I don't know
it's hard to say
it gets better visually I don't care I
just don't want to play it Kirby I'm
sorry
it's the hero Henry
we'll play shakiro next
all right dudes
I hope you enjoyed the condescending
lecture at the end of the Stream
[ __ ] people dude
I'm glad you enjoyed it Trevor
[Music]
right here
we will play
the KIRO next
it'll be fun I am gonna go eat some food
I'm hungry
and we'll be back either tomorrow or the
next day
have a good one guys
I'll see you soon
take care
bye bye bye